hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to outlast we are
currently shimmying on the outside of
the school building because for some
reason we were tossed in here again
don't know why but here we go and I have
no idea what you talked about nothing's
different so let's just focus on the
game here where we're going with it
because I don't know if we're getting
any sort of progress here it seems like
we've just been kind of like dancing
around the same subject not necessarily
going in circles but maybe that's par
well okay this is what I was talking
about here like this exact concept was
what I was talking about we all know
what happened we just don't know the
circumstances of why and how it came to
be and oh my god oh my god Oh alrighty
then where do we go from here
[Music]
why oh oh that's why was about all okay
all right you really threw that down in
a fit of rage didn't ya you showed that
one for okay Carrie I heard that hello
ah
good okay hi why am I in here what's
going on in here okay crying I guess
they're nothing ma'am I just heard
someone squeaking open the door and as
soon as it was gonna be bad for me okay
but it was good because it got a battery
out of it and everything's gonna be
hunky-dory now hello hi my name is
markiplier oh good another view of this
one oh hi I saw that I saw that you
can't hide from me I know where you live
oh it's coming back see I see I see you
what are you doing there what are you
doing just waiting for me at the other
place oh you are aren't you you are oh
you're waiting for oh it's right around
the corner and it's waiting for me oh
that's not good hello it should be
comforting and reassuring hello let's
see Jessica loves Blake oh she does Oh
Blake loved Jessica back even though
apparently the relationship is falling
apart which is awfully nice hey look
it's my recordings
hello hello oh that Colin Mochrie is
that Colin Mochrie right there okay I
know you're there I know you're there
behind me I know I know you're there
hang on give me a second see if there's
something to be done well that opened
with more prominence than I assumed it
would they're going to be shooting blood
out of these all right okay I'm always
hesitant but apparently there's no
reason for coming in here what about the
girls one yeah I got a bad feeling about
this one yeah I got a real bad feeling
about this one
no no eenie meenie miney moe
Oh Jessica Jessica Jessica Jessica
Jessica Jessica Jessica oh wait no
Jessica loves Blake Oh ah
akha says Oh lim is who my wife is
oh no oh no oh no oh good a bandage oh
I'm sure that's so sanitary way so
Jessica love Blake but then it was not
meant to be oh that's good okay I'm
gonna come see you now we're those of
you fighting oh my god Oh
[Music]
Oh Oh like the shadow work you're doing
on me I don't like that at all hey how
you doing okay all right you guys you
Hey so nice
alrighty then carrying on hello back in
the light
Oh ticking clock I thought those
something else all righty then
hello hello hello hello buddy in here
hello hi hello okay seeing a whole lot
of nothing here hi Oh God
likewise dark in here where did I get
here oh no can I hide I don't think I
can hide this isn't going to do me any
good is it he's gonna crouch down here
pretend like I don't exist
oh no no well
did something happen or am i okay well
I'm gonna go out there cuz I'm a brave
boy
hello I don't see anything anymore
hello okay nothing in here all right
trust in you trust in you I don't know
why I'm trusting you I shouldn't trust
you that's like the number one rule in
this game is don't trust anything and
here we go
I suppose yep here we go into the light
oh good alright there's nothing here we
explore the mystery stay pure with new
techniques I don't know if that's a good
good word of advice but I'm gonna try to
go out of here so I don't see why I
needed to come this way if it's all
gonna be old oh there's more oh I didn't
know there was gonna be more no one told
me there was gonna be more oh oh no oh
no oh no oh no oh no what kind of
library is this Oh No
let's scare the ever-loving bejesus out
of me don't do that one does it don't do
that again
fool me once shame on me fool me twice
shame you real hard full week thrice
pipe off with you shame me the hardest
you've ever is that a swastika oh hi oh
hi okay I've been shamed okay I don't
know it's way to go but I'm gonna try to
go and not go away so they're not gonna
let me go in and go well oh god damn it
mmm gonna make it oh [ __ ] oh oh okay
okay these are all dead ends but I don't
see the gup-e on the ground anymore
which makes me think maybe I got away
from it so that's good question mark
okay oh no oh no oh boy okay yeah I see
you know me history good so much
knowledge
oh boy that looks bad
anytime something's covered in frosted
glass I know that they're trying to hide
something
quiz usually vision I'm gonna be dead
very soon but I'm not gonna go down home
go this way hey hi I see you there what
are you doing hello hello oh alright
okay okay okay I'm Oh boobies
Oh [ __ ] you [ __ ] you just [ __ ] yo
Oh what is with this oh why is the
geometry all [ __ ] nutted oh boy oh
good oh good oh good I'm gonna happen
come behind me okay all right normal
normal everyday hi
hi baby God baby oh oh oh everything
seems now ah Blake I don't Blake doesn't
know Blake doesn't know like doesn't
know
ruh ruh ruh ruh fliction makes do we do
not know where do anything about that
[Applause]
Oh oh good I'm back in reality where am
i oh interact oh wait what am I supposed
to do is where am I supposed to push it
okay well that was an adventurous time
let's review what we definitely on the
top floor the mine entrance is usually
on the top floor how do you know that I
have lots of friends I don't know I
don't know I don't know but at least I
think I got everything in there okay so
we got a can't go through here because
it's all blocked up anyway this is wait
this is exactly where I was wasn't it
then I didn't make it very far or maybe
I did I just have no idea anymore with
all this stuff
okay so I think I can go up there looks
like a place I can go maybe maybe it's
not I like my ability to determine where
I've been where I've gone is just thrown
out the window and keep being talked in
and out of reality like this why
the thing I haven't taken much damage
still raining blood though which is yell
very convenient convenient not
convenient I like consistency in my life
I like consistency in my life okay
well don't try to spook me unless you're
actually trying to spook me here oh this
is where wait hi okay maybe it all looks
the same so it's hard to tell where I've
been oh hi hi hi hi hiiii oh no need to
go back there no need to go back all
right let's not be screaming like a
little [ __ ] baby until we know what we
need to scream at oh boy sounds like
there's a lot to scream out over here
okay all right come on okay I'm a brave
boy I'm a brave boy I'm a brave boy
there ain't nothing wrong here a wookie
opening this like mouse I hear a lot of
things I just don't see a lot of things
oh I see a lot of things I see someone
over there oh hi okay where is this
going
I don't know what it's going where's it
going oh God where is it going where's
it going I don't know I don't know wow I
did this wrong oh it's wrong okay I
think I need to push it out there maybe
I don't know what it's going oh maybe
actually close this oh I see it I see it
I see it I see it okay close dad
hopefully I'm gonna be okay they can't
seem to get to me which is good they're
just making a lot of noise which is good
good they're exercising their vocal
cords they're doing all their vocal
warm-ups that's good you can't follow hi
okay all right
but now Wow no that was dumb that was
real dumb I was real dumb huh I was dumb
dahm dahm dahm dahm okay so I don't need
to close that off I just need to get
this out there quicker huh I need to
actually get this on the wall they're
not miss my jump like an idiot okay like
that and then go up there
boy hey ho are you guys hi hello my body
Wow [ __ ] god dammit who you goddamn
idiot you [ __ ]
douche nozzle he said Garbo where am I
going off well that was not correct I
think I don't know where I'm going I
don't know where I'm going where am i
gone where we go well I thought wait
possible to see where I'm going when
everything looks the same
okay here we go again I guess geez um
everything looks the same everything is
the same
how am I supposed to know where I'm
supposed to jump Oh Nellie oh I'm so
it's a crawl oh okay
oh man it may just be my panic brain not
taking in that information but it's just
a little bit difficult there's a little
bit difficult and these heretics they
want me bad no well I was very clearly
on the RAM oh no no no no
where the prick can I go oh wow oh no oh
my Alabama summit hi this is ridiculous
okay this is just a little bit
ridiculous okay there's just a little
bit ridiculous okay I just want to say
that right now it's a little bit
ridiculous because I am very clearly
doing the things that I intend to do and
it is not doing them back to me it's not
treating me with the respect that I
deserve
all right I must stop whining and
complaining a Mexican please better okay
so you need to walk across this very
slowly right I got it I got it I got it
hi guys it's all good talking talking I
got this even feeling easy squeazy okay
oh yeah I can do this all right
oh hey what's up welcome to my
neighborhood oh here we go not paying
attention to where I'm going where I'm
going yes yes
okay good we're good we're good we're
good we're good we're good what oh okay
okay all right
uh-huh okay well I guess this makes
sense considering in the real world I'd
be still be running away hmm okay okay
where am I going
he's holding open a bunch of mystery
doors here is that what I'm doing
looking for places to hide is that what
I'm doing in the real world
oh boy one of what the heretics think of
me as I'm babbling I'm just completely
lost of where I'm spoken to going I
don't I don't think I'm supposed to do
that ah yeah that's not what I was
supposed to do ah I was very dumb oh hey
how's it going all right so if that's
not what I was supposed to do then maybe
what I was supposed to do is either not
go in that bathroom at all or hide in
one of the stalls which is entirely
possible let's try this one's more
without being too aggressively stupid
well I'm obviously supposed to go in
here so let me try hiding in one of the
stalls will never check the one at the
end oh god oh god oh what to do there oh
what to do oh I know I could crawl under
them I didn't even think of that I don't
even think of that
I could probably crawl under them
couldn't I okay
all right we're getting somewhere I'm
gonna keep this down just because the
warping is a little bit disorienting for
me I know it's got acute orienting for
some of you guys wow baby I went into
this all way now anyway so I could
probably if I start over here I might be
able to crawl underneath I'm not 100%
sure about that nope
this was not correct Oh No maybe when it
hits maybe when it hits I got to open it
smack into them yes
[Music]
I got you oh yeah I got smash you smash
you [ __ ]
- you [ __ ] smash you [ __ ]
Hey
so I'm supposed to do about that why am
I here right here I don't know why I'm
here but okay that doesn't make a lot of
sense but okay I'll take it
I'll take the victory for one I got it
unless you just horrific Li broke the
game or something which is entirely
possible but maybe doctor okay alright
wool hi oh gee it is maybe up there
anything up there am Swiss to see
anything no pretty girl supposed to go
down that one oh okay alright thank you
for clarifying I think I'm not trying to
hide I'm trying to run there's a
distinct difference no I don't think so
I don't need your help I don't think
anyone needs your help
hello I'll never let you go okay good
maybe good I supposed to go out the
window again this where I came in I
think I'm supposed to go out here yeah
yeah Oh
whoa
hello okay we're out here now apparently
this is good good welcome change to what
we were doing out there right
can I go down can I jump down or
something
okay I guess I'm supposed to climb over
to the right maybe I don't know how I
even got here
I mean it looks like I'm supposed to be
able to drop down over there but maybe
not
no can I can I drop down please I'd like
to get off this wild ride I want to get
off mr. bones wild ride please let me
drop there we go okay got it
I've got a Preston crowds but whoa
that's a little skeevy oh wait what are
you doing okay so scared that you would
start backtracking on me oh that's
something tells me something tells me I
shouldn't go I shouldn't go over there
oh forget knocked off all right here we
go whoo gee that barely works okay
oh boy hard to see everything in the
raining blood there was anything else
was a document there there was nothing I
could have documented in the dream world
with the quota or dream world that might
be more real than this world here you
know okay there's got to be a place to
go from up here but as far as I can
ah-oh
well hand me that oh hi
are you still coming after me you guys
are really swarming this place I don't
know why I'm not interesting to you just
because I'm the father of the Antichrist
or something like that
Shelby Oh Howie my taxi Hey okay all
right what do I do by the way down okay
I'm gonna do this right now
oh boy oh boy still running running oh
boy oh boy come on come on come on come
on crawl faster please
faster faster faster okay nothing to
worry about just act cool calm collected
it's a crack cocaine oh no oh no where
where where where mop-up always up
either up or down no matter what I say
okay here we go come on come on you can
stand up at any time now let's got here
[Applause]
isn't farther come on come on yeah
there's a big strong boy
ma'am baby okay good okay good okay good
we made it to the top which is somehow
somehow the top is the entrance to the
mine which goes into the earth don't ask
me why that makes sense because it does
not still rain in blood no idea why
that's happening but it's still raining
blood and I still haven't been injured
just because I've been killed every
single time I've tried to do something
so well let's just go into the mind
because that's obviously what we need to
do ah last time I was in an elevator
it's coming what's coming the elevator
am I not in the elevator
am I not oh oh
oh no oh no oh no oh no oh no oh yeah
we're gonna be us was that okay was I
supposed to call them and then oh no I
can't move oh why did that happen I
didn't see that happen there's gonna do
things to me not tell me about the thing
that you're doing it yeah son of a [ __ ]
where do they even bother Matt I think I
got a cycle round and eventually make my
way back there back a little bit
[ __ ] huh
gotta keep moving though got some
complaining keep moving I'm more
complaining for the steak a blade here
because you have to deal with all this
yes because there are multiple
reincarnation as he dies over and over
again to my own stupidity so I'm not
complaining for my sake I'm complaining
for Blake here okay so yeah I got a
circle back around but ow
apparently I'm going slow now why stop
going slow and just hurry the heck up oh
no come on are you joking me right now
are you kidding my Rhonda oh yeah low
and steady wins the race don't it yeah
oh yeah now is the time to be out of
shape wicked diction [ __ ] you guys
poor Blake again he is running on what
I've got to be fumes at this point
because he's got so much blood loss so
many broken bones so many bruises and
he's been sprinting since he got here
you know it's not actually all that
amazing that he might be running out of
steam lit yeah her name is Lynn her name
is in Nederland soft ATP all right
I love elevator ride
oh good of course the kid stuck every
elevator in every horror game ever get
stuck fall down even in the original
outlast this happened
I better get out of here
back it out here I tried I cried I
really tried I tried there boy
Oh
[Music]
Wow okay
okay 800 feet down
[Music]
[Applause]
okay I guess this is my stuff
all right here we go don't fall on my
head please oh it almost fell on my head
how did I call that one ah good who
thought that was gonna be bad for me it
was gonna be bad but alas I'm too smart
for you now let's see what this means
poor trend I was never gonna get out
yeah I know I knew it at least I'd be
there with her well that's awfully nice
to think about your own demise are you
talking about Jessica are you talking
about Linds oh I didn't this one nowhere
I missed it probably in the one second
that I put my camera down man or
probably actually it happened when it
might have bugged out and it set my save
a little bit farther than I actually was
a little bit odd well that's fine I
haven't been completionist yet but hi
hello I am in the center of the heretic
abode right now so I am in the heart of
their entire operation so at this point
I'm going to invading their sanctum so
even already then when I'm coming land
oh Jenny beyond or I mean the heretics
wanted to have the baby that's the idea
if there even is a baby which even Lin
was kind of like maybe there's a baby
it's probably not even my baby maybe
it's gonna be one of those circumstances
where like I know I'm not trying to
excuse or anything but it's like you
know okay alright then well we'll do it
I don't know what the hell happened
there but uh we're just gonna do it like
this play why wait what wait what wait
wait
okay all right that was weird what what
was the hem explicit at what is that
what is that is that a scholar what is
that what is that what kind of animal is
that that a goat hand I have no idea Oh
oh boy well there's a nice body oh girl
oh crap leg
oh boy
to go the dark path first nothing there
nothing in the crumbles oh hi
hidden success okay alrighty then here
we go but [ __ ] okay oh I thought I was
gonna be something terrifying and
something I haven't seen or it's just
you hey doing buddy you look good for
you they live down here
no not lift I had to find Lin
I hope they hadn't already well that's
obviously not Lin Lin wasn't that buff
and muscular I mean I know they
displayed the skin all that but ah come
on keep that's Lin no way oh good a
sacrificial pit of some sort okay Noble
ISM oh good I'll grind I'm gonna go in
that hole in just a second I just wanted
to make sure that I found everything
that I needed to find here we go
Oh battery oh that's enticing I want
that let me reload I'll grab that
battery and then we'll be on the way it
plans everything marked by blood
everything is marked by blood every
escape route every single way that
everybody's ever gone marked by blood
outside raining blood in here blood
everywhere
Oh in your food Banda great good stuff
through and through
oh well battery I guess they're
expecting hey how you doing there don't
look immediately behind you yeah that
wouldn't be the thing that you were
looking for okay what do we got here oh
maybe I need to hide because they're
upcoming yeah as bowl of water seems
like a good idea why did I do this why
did I do this so I just need to stay
here cuz they're a comin maybe because
there was the lockers over there that
would have been a better place died but
fine I'm just kind of okay I think I'm
fine I think I'm fine okay
think I'm fine
it seems to be okay oh I see Springs can
you just calm down for one goddamn
second I try to be quiet then you start
big banging noise it's [ __ ] goddamn
it I believe you did whatever David is a
soup top David you do okay maybe you
string quartet was trying to warn me
about some linear but I still don't
appreciate it none so something I need
to be afraid about thing there's some
reason that I needed to crawl into this
hole and hide please tell me that it is
that way that it is and I am NOT being a
big dumb idiot okay I'm a trustee on
this one I'm trusting you don't don't
push me over like this
don't use me over okay I think I'm okay
don't do Smeal okay that's gonna be
locked that's probably the way that I'm
gonna be coming back once I grab Lynn
and everything's gonna be hunky-dory and
I'm gonna get on the [ __ ] high
what we'll you kidding me it's a
surprise door Oh death really you're
gonna dick me over with a surprise door
Oh death oh joy Oh frabjous day
take your there I mean you're coming
this way are you don't know what oh okay
oh I was supposed to see that he went
through there and then man this has been
the most jump scary episode of this
entire game
I am not having none
okay impressive that's the only thing I
can think to say at that point what am I
looking at huh oh I need to record
something
can you hold very still hold very still
very still hold very still very still Oh
No just kill me oh oh we're starting oh
we're starting here really I need to
recover I'm not back idea where am I
always off she worked him joking me
aimer when did you get so douche tastic
what when did you get so douchey game
what did he decide to do [ __ ] off a
hundred thousands I'm prick dude dude oh
alright
close this locket I suppose oh my god
even my string quartet is getting
frustrated this is ridiculous
oh come on me all I can do is laugh all
I can do is laugh
I've died four times in this episode
that I've got no goddamn game oh I don't
give the moment's respite and my god if
this didn't Frank up to maximum do [ __ ]
I'm gonna go hide in here I suppose sure
maybe this one isn't a good a good one
to be and maybe this one is hiiii ah oh
man I'm not actually I'm not angry at
the game I'm not angry at the game I'm
just amazed I'm amazed at it I'm amazed
at its level of deuce tree
good thing I switched lockers and good
thing they're not very thorough string
quartet are you kidding me right now I'm
gonna I'm gonna go for it I think I can
hurdle over that board right in front of
the one right there I think I can hurdle
over that because it doesn't seem like
she's gonna let me stuns him like she's
gonna walk away so here we go hi I was
right all right I was right I was like
oh I can do that
oh boy okay keep going keep going I
don't know where we're going - oh not
that way oh you didn't see nothing digit
string quartet let me know when it's
cool hop out I'm gonna heal they're
checking the thing again grab that book
scoop it in
what am I supposed to do about this
nobody weird oh my god nice ass
that is quite the buttocks okay but he's
going leaving even so that's good so
that means maybe make my way down this
way
oh no I can't Oh what do I do
there's no way to go around circularly
unless I can lead them around here okay
you're gonna follow me
you're gonna ring around the rosey baby
bring around my Rosie okay here we go
and now we go now we go and now we go
now we go oh god damn it why why I need
you to record that other thing I was
down the other way record dick Rick my
dick and prick that dick Rick that oh no
he's here oh yeah oh yeah recording it
recording it don't creep up behind me
don't be a douche don't be a douche
don't be this we do don't we do let me
get it let me get let me get it yes okay
there we go
now we can go now we can go where are we
oh hi okay all right
my interact with this what that's going
to do oh [ __ ] whoo maybe not [ __ ] maybe
good
oh wait no okay
so I need to let this go a little
farther and then divert it maybe push it
the other way so let me pull this
and then switch it and then hopefully
that'll lead me down the right path
right
or maybe I need to go the left way
because pushing this along distance
would make the most sense nor was there
anything over there that I needed how
there probably was wasn't it and let me
just you know what I'm gonna go this way
this because I feel like maybe this is
the secret and it was like because this
seems I don't know it's impossible to
say which way is the right way which way
is the wrong word go I'm wanting to tell
me tell you why
oh no this is the end way to go oh no oh
you'll be fine de lijn nothing matters
but Lin you're right decorated with the
dead a Czech faces looking for Lin
looking for my own oh you're gonna wax
poetic Oh
let's keep going with that one oh no
this is the Gospel of not this is the
secret ah
all right and in the moments before her
birth the Antichrist shall wake even in
the womb and a woe and misery will bleed
and corrupt the earth as Jesus Christ of
Nazareth dethroned death in glory of God
the Antichrist of temple gate shall set
the grim horsemen back upon their throne
unless he is murdered in a bloody cradle
but Ezekiel shall judge the unborn
spider I'd lamb by knife and by fire and
the righteous shall proclaim an Alleluia
and ye shall see heaven open and come to
earth and as he Kyle shall sit astride a
white horse
his eyes shall be a flame upon his head
will be all the crowns of the earth and
he shall take a new name as up to the
world of God for he shall be clothed in
the vesture drift in blood
his new name shall be known to none but
himself and the angel savvy carrion
birds who feast upon the flesh of kings
the flesh of mothers the flesh of mighty
men the flesh of horses and them that
sit on them the flesh of freemen and
slaves and if they feed on the flesh of
that damned child in heaven is yours but
if that child draws breath if the eyes
of the Antichrist are allowed to take in
the light of the world they shall
swallow the light of the world then
death shall reign again an endless
suffering shall reward those who revel
in their suffering an endless regrets of
torture the righteous in the Amedda
Keable regrets of sin and shame well
that's a pleasant thought to end this
episode on but I found it so good for me
and thank you for that anyway so that's
all the time I got for this episode here
we did find some things I try to be as
thorough as I could be but even in the
panic and the the endless cycle of death
that I was subjected to
I still miss one or two things so sorry
about that but I'll try to do better in
the next step so thank you everybody so
much for watching let me know how i'm
doing the comments below and as always I
will see you in the next video bye
[Music]